okay. Last week I did a fully detailed breakdown
of exactly how it is that the youtube algorithm
is doing a lot to hurt the David Pakman show
and last week I focused mostly on the ways
in which our traffic from youtube suggested
video feed has fallen off of a cliff and that
story resonated with people hugely.
The Youtube clip that we did, where I just
explained here is how the Youtube Algorithm
is crushing us when it comes to suggesting
our content has surpassed 200,000 views in
just a few days. And as a reminder, in case
you didn't see that or you forgot about it,
we used to regularly get about three and a
half million views per month from Youtube,
uh, including our content in the suggested
videos. So this means that you're browsing
around content on youtube that is not David
Pakman show content and uh, alongside it or
down below it, youtube will say, hey, here's
some stuff that you might like. And some of
those clips are from the David Pakman show.
We used to get, as I said, about three and
a half million views per month from that algorithmic
series of suggestions. That number dropped
to barely 1.5 million in June. So the short
fall, just in that bucket of views, the suggested
content from youtube is 2 million views per
month.
Okay, a drop of 2 million views per month.
Listen, most youtube channels don't get 2
million views a year, nevermind per month.
And for us, our shortfall in views just from
the suggested video algorithm is about 2 million
views per month. That's a huge amount of revenue
for us. As I've said before, a youtube terms
and conditions don't allow partners to talk
specifically about revenue, but it's a lot
of money to lose 2 million views a month.
Just from that. And what it appears is happening
is that youtube is recommending more establishment
legacy corporate channels over the David Pakman
show. So whereas before, if you went and looked
at a clip of whatever, I'm a Stephen Co bear
along the side, previously it was more likely
that a David Pakman show video would be recommended.
Now it's more likely that you're going to
get recommendations from CNN, uh, from the
other late night talk shows from establishment
legacy corporate sources.
So this is a, a direct negative to independent
media sources like ours. I also last week
alluded to another piece of the problem, and
this is a completely unrelated problem that's
also absolutely destructive. And it makes
me wonder, is youtube trying to get me to
quit? Are they trying to get me to just stop
doing what we do? And the problem is what
I would consider a completely brand safe videos
with nothing controversial, nothing problematic,
nothing gory or violent or anything like that.
Being demonetized individually. This is a
double crush of the David Pakman show youtube
channel because on the one hand, youtube is
recommending our content less frequently instead
recommending corporate legacy content. And
on the other hand it's making it so that even
when our subscribers come to our channel and
watch our content, more and more of those
videos aren't running ads, meaning that we
end up earning no revenue from those videos
even when people do watch them.
And this has now exploded in the last three
or four days with completely innocuous videos
being completely demonetized and it's happening
very often to videos that do really, really
well. This next example should stun you. Yesterday
we did a story. The story was about Donald
Trump's press conference over the weekend
in Japan. The video was called visibly sweaty,
Trump confused by busing and liberalism. The
is nine minutes long. It contains no profanity.
It contains no descriptions of violence. It's
not at all about uh, anything gory. There's
no gory images or vocabulary. There's no discussions
of war or terrorism or anything like it. Uh,
there's no mention of race or racism in the
title. In the description in the tags, it's
two clips of Trump talking to reporters, Kristen
Welker and I believe Peter Alexander at a
press conference in Japan, the video was instantly
demonetized when we uploaded it to youtube.
Now this doesn't mean when it published, it
was demonetized because somebody complained
about the video or whatever the case may be
before it even published. Just when we uploaded
it, it was automatically demonetized by Youtube
Algorithm. Here's a screenshot. The yellow
dollar sign signifies that the video has been
marked as not brand safe, meaning we make
no money from it. And despite youtube, having
told me a couple of weeks ago that they will
be when we believe that the algorithm has
incorrectly identified a video as not eligible
for monetization, they say you press the appeal
button and we're going to try to review those
appeals within an hour or as close to it as
possible. 16 hours later as of this morning,
the video still demonetized after 150,000
views in the first 16 hours. This is a really
good video for us. 10,000 views an hour for
16 hours is very solid for us and completely
lost revenue on it that we will never regain.
We spend time researching and gathering the
clips. We prepare a commentary, we edit the
video, we upload it again to a a bunch of
views and engagement and comments and we lose
all the revenue because of this demonetization.
Now let me be very clear. This is not about
me thinking I have a right to monetize on
youtube. Youtube can have a policy. Youtube
can monetize or d, monetize whoever they want,
assuming that they're not. For example, targeting
people on the basis of their race or ethnicity
or religion. If the, as long as they're not
saying any videos done by people of X-rays,
we will not monetize. That I believe would
be against the law. But I have no rights to
Youtube ad revenue. So I don't want the, the
Conservatives to misunderstand my argument.
The problem is we're playing the game the
way youtube wants us to play it.
We're uploading content that is not in violation
of any of the terms and conditions for monetization.
I'm not even arguing that this is a left versus
right thing. There are left wingers who are
having this problem and there are right wingers
who are having this problem. If I had been,
for example, uploading videos where I am bullying
a specific youtube or, or journalist for their
race or their sexual orientation. Okay. That
I understand if we were showing footage of
bloody a military conflict, even though, by
the way, I think it's actually good for us
not to be disconnected from the bloody reality
and the horrors of war. Uh, I understand that
brands don't necessarily want to advertise
on videos that contain violent war footage
for example, but it's none of that. And in
the last month, youtube has taken a decidedly
anti independent turn. I believe that that's
what this is about.
They are suggesting more and more corporate
videos over independently produced videos
and using politics. They are monetizing corporate
legacy videos on the same topics over which
we are being demonetized. And now that a ton
of you have heard about this, uh, many of
you have fortunately said we're not going
to allow this to happen and I have to thank
you for that. June ended up being our biggest
month ever for new members and we have to
keep it going. And I've run some numbers.
If we have three more months of new members
like we had in June, we will be able to laugh
away this demonetization issue and we will
be able to just do the content and it won't
matter what's monetized. So if you don't like
what's going on here, and I know that there
are people on both sides of the political
aisle that don't like this, just pick up a
membership, okay?
This is really cheap. Every person that signs
up is giving us immunity from this fiasco.
Every dollar we receive through membership
is a dollar we don't need or have to worry
about from youtube. We're not going to go
away assuming they don't ban us. Okay? Make
sure you subscribe to our channel. Make sure
you hit the bell icon and tell Youtube you
actually want to be notified when we post
video content. Keep watching the clips and
please sign up for a membership if you can.
It has not been going well on youtube lately,
but thanks to you we are building a stronger
foundation so we will hopefully be less exposed
to the whims of the youtube monetization algorithm.
And by the way, if you go to David pakman.com/membership
and the prices strike you as high for your
budget, I totally understand that. Use the
coupon code. This is 2020, it'll chop 40%
off the cost of your membership. Let me know
what you think about this. A, I'm on Instagram
at David Dot. Pacman, the show on Instagram
at David Pakman show. I will keep you apprised
of developments in this, in this area because
I know that
many of you do care about what's going on.